extreme heat gripping the valley as
thousands of people fill into town for a
big weekend here in las vegas
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdis and i'm brian loftis we hit 116
degrees today at mccarran just one
degree shy
of an all-time record high the heat even
impacting flights today
yeah with temperatures staying high
through the weekend orca mana joining us
now with how you can stay safe
orco well denise and brian it's past 11
o'clock right now and it's still
sweltering outside if i try to take the
temperature of this asphalt here
you can see it doesn't even register
that means the ground is still
hotter than 110 degrees it's only going
to get worse this weekend
so we have some tips to keep you cool
looking to enjoy some time away trevor
and jarelyn lawrence are visiting vegas
this weekend
excited to see bruno mars at the park
mgm
24 karat magic in the air
[Music]
also in the air the extreme heat the
valley flirting with
near record temperatures the next couple
days we didn't know that before i bought
the ticket
but this dallas duo has a plan to stay
cool
i don't think we've seen this type of
heat before but we'll stay inside in ac
and drink lots of water they just go
poolside and try to hang out
get by a cabana get a little tropical
drink and enjoy
some shade it's going to be dangerously
hot steve smith with red rock search and
rescue says heat exhaustion and heat
stroke are big concerns
heat exhaustion can cause weakness
excessive sweating and even nausea and
vomiting heat stroke is even worse
you could go in the seizures you can go
in the coma very very severe headache
and you're very dry you're done sweating
you have no more fluids in you
whether you're hiking on the trails or
spending a day on the strip smith has
two main tips you need to keep your head
covered and cool
and you need to hydrate and the lawrence
family is prepared
if we tried to endure the pandemic for
18 months i think i can endure 115
degrees for two days
now experts say it's also a good idea to
keep some items in the trunk of your car
like towels and an ice box to keep your
water cool
they also say you should probably go
outside earlier in the day
or later not during the hottest time of
the day
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now